the humorless left is now so
trigger-happy they are attacking things
that have not even happened yet we will
analyze the hysteria that is ripping
America apart your Amazon II will then
explain how to bring our nation back
together in his book the virtue of
nationalism then a new poll shows
Americans no longer care if political
candidates are religious while Pope
Francis blames the devil for exposing
the corruption of Bishops hmm I wonder
if one has to do with the other one all
that and much more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the left is going after Norm Macdonald
before norm MacDonald's show even airs
we will talk about that and explain why
but first I need to thank a wonderful
sponsor you are looking at my face right
now you see these baby soft features
this sweet look at that clean shave
that's because I use Dollar Shave Club
and I love Dollar Shave Club I love
everything that Dollar Shave Club has to
offer I love the amber and lavender body
wash I love the big cloud good shake
hand cream where do they get these names
these are good I love the even love the
one wipe Charlies because I use them to
take my makeup off you can use them for
something else they're also used as a
portable bidet the one wife charlie
wipes they have boogies specific pomade
oh baby they got everything my favorite
thing they have is their razor they have
a six blade executive razor it's the
best razor I've ever used and look I'm a
man who is easily satisfied by the very
best you know I have simple tastes I've
always used really good razors this is
the best one I've ever used it is so
good and but all of their products are
top-notch right now you can get an
amazing deal on one of their starter
sets I recommend the daily essential
starter set it comes with everything
head over to dollarshaveclub.com slash
qoph FAC of EF EF e the dollar the daily
essentials starter set comes with the
amber lavender body cleanser which is
one of their top things but you can get
any of them pick your own DSC starter
set for just 5 bucks after your starter
set products ship at a regular price
that is dollarshaveclub.com / coffe fa
co v fe f ec which starter set works for
you dollarshaveclub.com / go FFA co v fe
fe
really good products so they're going
after noir MacDonald you know I've
referred to norm on this show before
he's my favorite living comedian I know
he's the favorite comedian of a lot of
people out there - and you know you can
go down a YouTube wormhole of all the
norm clips and the reason we're talking
about norm now is he's getting a show on
Netflix in I think two or three days I
think it's airing either this week or
next week and so the left is already
trying to get him now it norm it's not
like he's some Brooks Brothers wearing
conservative it's not like you know he's
this right-wing apologist or something
he's just not politically correct and
he's a comedian who cares about actually
making people laugh unlike men net
unlike Kathy Griffin unlike people who
they go for claps and not laughs norm
actually goes for laughs and so they're
so angry at him because he isn't
politically correct because he isn't
making jokes about Trump because jokes
about Trump are super duper lame he did
this interview yesterday or two days ago
with The Hollywood Reporter where he was
asked what do you think about Roseanne
Barr and louis c.k both of whom are
friends of his going back decades I
believe and he said well you know they
were really broken up about the whole
thing and they're really sorry and I'm
I'm glad to see them back on their feet
something to that effect and they are
pillory him for this he made a comment
he said that the me2 movement got a
little bit crazy and so he's glad that
there's some balance you know that
because of their look there were false
accusations some of the people who were
accusers are now being accused of sexual
harassment themselves some of the people
who were accusers have details have come
out where they were in consensual
relationships not non-consensual
relationships so he's just pointing out
that it maybe got a little out of hand
and it's glad that it's not as crazy as
it was before he is being raked over the
coals they're already trying to cancel
his show there were actually people
tweeting who said I hate his show it's
boring and terrible the show hasn't
premiered yet and all I look I like norm
so I want to defend his show and I look
forward to watching the show but what
this is really about is all of the
hysteria that is gripping all of America
we're all so trigger-happy for those of
you who are not familiar with norm just
to give you a little context here as a
joke he did on David Letterman's last
show I think you'll understand why he's
such a favorite on this program here
there is one country that worries me
though not Iraq not Iran that North
Korea the only country that really
worries me is the country of Germany I
don't know if you guys are history buffs
or not but
in the early part of the previous
century Germany he decided to go to war
and who did they go to war with the
world had never been tried before and so
you figure that would take about five
seconds for the world to win but no it
was actually close
[Applause]
then about then about 30 years pass and
Germany decides again to go to Oran
again it chooses as its enemy the world
and this time they have that guy can I
actually that guy I'm not even gonna
dignify him by saying his name but I
mean you know I've done but you think at
that point the world will go listen
Germany here's the deal you know ya be a
country no more on account of you keep
attacking the world so you get the sense
we've talked about similar things before
on this show with due respect to our
German viewers and listeners so anyway
the left is very upset because he's not
being mean to Trump burries not telling
this joke or that joke he's actually
telling jokes just that are funny you
know and that you're not allowed to do
that anymore were in the Nannette comedy
world now so he norm actually was booted
from the Jimmy Kimmel show because of
this non traversée this is the stupidest
non traversée since the mark Duplass
thing you remember the whole Mark
Duplass he said I kind of like ben
shapiro now it's all career is ruined
this is the stupidest non traversée
since then Jimmy Kimmel goes up to Norm
Macdonald say you can't come on the show
because you said that you still sort of
like Roseanne Barr and you still sort of
like Louie CK my producers are crying
because of your comments my producers
are crying Millennials in the workforce
folks safe spaces at The Tonight Show I
buy though I will actually give it to
those Millennial producers certainly
they undoubtedly millennial producers
because they were able to negotiate in
warm milk and pacifiers into their
nightly contracts oh great good work I
mean that's the art of the deal right
there Oh Jimmy Fallon I'm sorry was
Jimmy Fallon not Jimmy Kimmel is really
sad because those two guys used to be
different people that one was the crazy
lefty one was just you know sort of
having fun and now unfortunately looks
like Jimmy Fallon is falling into that
left-wing claptrap too easily confused
though sorry to say that
it's all of this trigger-happy hysteria
producers shouldn't be crying because of
a common sense observation they should
people in show business is a horrible
industry and we know that this town is
rife with emotional physical and sexual
abuse and they're crying because a guy
made a normal observation this we're so
the left is being hysterical that's what
this is that's the only way to describe
it it is hysteria get ahold of yourself
people get ahold of yourself that you
people should calm down this is what you
know I think this is all Trump's fault
this obviously is all Trump's fault
because when Trump was elected everyone
was told the world was gonna go to hell
in a handbasket and then he was
president for two years now and
everything is going fine now common
sense your gut instinct would tell you
this would make people change their mind
everyone would calm down because of this
but that's not how people work in real
life what actually happens when they're
all they're totally hysterical they're
expecting the worst
something good happens they ignore the
reality and double down on their
prejudice they double down so they say
will it but Trump is president so things
can't be going well so it's really awful
Zara and that's why they're getting
crazier and crazier as the economy
improves as the jobless numbers go down
as the world is at peace relative peace
they're not getting happier they're
getting crazier they're getting this is
how conspiracy theories work when you a
guy has a conspiracy theory and then you
tell you point out the holes in his
conspiracy theory he doesn't stop
believing a conspiracy he just thinks
you're part of the conspiracy he gets
even Wilder so you saw this morning Joe
humiliated himself yesterday was a
despicable column on 9/11 he said that
Donald Trump is worse than 9/11 worse
than 9/11 he said quote for those of us
still believing that Islamic extremists
hate America because of the freedoms we
guarantee to all people the gravest
threat Trump poses to our national
security is the damage done daily to
America's image as the New York Times is
Roger Cohen wrote the month after
Trump's election America is an idea
strip away freedom human rights
democracy the rule of law from what the
United States represents to the world in
America itself
is gutted America's gutted under Donald
Trump according to morning Joe and some
dumb-dumb over at the New York Times
first of all America is not just an idea
America is a country found
in part on ideas end on a tradition in a
land at a particular time with
particular people so not just an idea
doesn't float in this rationalist if
you're real cloud it's a real place it's
a country it's a nation which we're
gonna be talking about in a little bit
but also does anybody believe that the
Donald Trump has stripped America of
freedom human rights democracy nor the
left one who disturb America of
democracy they wanted to overturn they
still want to overturn a presidential
election they but Donald Trump has only
increased the freedom experienced by
Americans deregulated the government let
Americans keep more of their money is
America gutted of course not but they
can't admit this because they were so
wrong in their predictions they can't
admit it so they have to get crazier
Morning Joe called Trump a politician
who has done more damage to the dream of
America than any foreign adversary ever
could Donald Trump worst them Pearl
Harbor I guess worse than blowing up the
harbor killing all those Americans worse
than killing 3,000 Americans do you
really believe that maybe he does but
what a morally idiotic fool if that's
what he really believes Jeff Bennett at
NBC the White House correspondent
tweeted out he said quote Trump in
Shanksville talks to US troops fighting
the Menace of radical Islamic terrorism
a controversial campaign catchphrase
that he didn't use last year a
controversial catchphrase radical
Islamic terrorism is a controversial
catch controversial to whom it's just
reality it just describes it but NBC
can't admit the reality because for
years and years Barack Obama wouldn't
use the term the Democrats wouldn't use
the term and but it turns out the enemy
that we're fighting or radical Islamic
terrorists or they they're not moderate
so they're not moderate they're radical
they're not Methodist they're Islamic
and they're not legal participants in
war they're terrorists they're radical
Islamic terrorists that's not a
controversial catchphrase that's just a
basic description of who they are but as
we've seen this time and time again 65
terrorist attacks in Europe in just the
last four years as we've seen it time
and time again a stabbing happens to be
happening every month or so in in Europe
we've had seven I think of a seven might
have been nine terrorist attacks since
2001 in the United States
we can't the more that we see the
evidence the more that we see who this
is
the more the left is going to double
down and pretend that it isn't happening
this this is very important because this
hysteria seems to be ripping the country
apart people have always been a little
hysterical they referred to Ronald
Reagan as a Nazi it's the election of
Hitler as well they so everything they
said about Trump they said about Ronald
Reagan but now because of social media
this is sort of the downside of social
media it seems like it's so much louder
that it's happening in a different way
it does appear to be tearing the country
apart Morning Joe talking about America
being gutted fortunately we have an
expert your amazon e who wrote this
great book the virtue of nationalism but
first I need to invite you into my
boudoir come on in it's okay come on let
me I'll give you a little tour around
what I'm sleeping on purple mattress
baby
that purple mattress is saving my
marriage I can say it certainly say that
because I had a dinky little queen-size
mattress before now I've got that
California King thanks to purple and
purple is the trick I don't sleep very
well I've always I've always had
mattresses that don't feel great or a
little quirk in the neck or whatever
purple mattress feels terrific it was
designed by rocket scientists I've told
you I have a very simple tastes I'm a
man of simple tastes I'm easily
satisfied by the best and that is purple
mattress it is this brand-new material
it was developed by an actual rocket
scientist it is not like the memory foam
that you are used to it is unique
because it's firm and soft at the same
time I know that sounds like a
contradiction in terms it is not you
just got to try it to find out and it
sleeps really cool I obviously being of
Sicilian descent I pour sweat in the
middle of the night it will keep you
really cool it's really nice you're
gonna love purple right now my listeners
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's pretty
good free purple pillow so say that
three times best in addition to the
great free gifts they're offering
site-wide you'll also get that pillow go
to purple comm use the promo code
Coface EO v f EF e that way you can
think about me every time you lay your
head on your pillow
purple comm promo code cough fac of e fe
fe that's the only way to get the free
pillow use promo code cough fac o BF e f
e wow that's really good
now we're gonna share that together too
you're gonna think of me every time you
lie down on your bed
here is dr. Hassan II dr. Hassan II
thank you so much for being here
thanks for having me I have told you
already extensively how much I love this
book it is so good it is an argument
that you don't see people make it is
totally politically incorrect it is a
vigorous defense of nationalism we've
heard in the conservative movement for
years and years even even on the right
that nationalism is a bad word Bill
Buckley would always say I love
patriotism but I hate nationalism as
though there were some distinction
between the two which I can't figure out
what is the it you know in in five words
or less you know in 20 seconds here what
what is the argument for nationalism the
simplest argument is is the world better
off if it's governed by a diversity of
independent nations each one with its
own different customs and traditions in
in constitutional and religious issues
each one an experiment in what it is for
human societies to to live is that
better or should we go for some kind of
centralized rules-based order that
somebody's going to decide about and
then impose on the rest of the world the
argument is that the first is far
superior it's not utopia but it's better
well it what is amazing in the book is
it's a it's a simple premise which is
that there are two orders of the world
you can have an imperial order the order
of Empire or you can have a national
order you trace that national order all
the way back to the Bible and you trace
the imperial order all the way up to
institutions that we don't even think of
necessarily as imperial the European
Union the United Nations all these super
national organizations oh why is it that
the progressives seem to be advocating
for Empire and how is the EU no
different than the empires of Antep are
as the progressives don't don't forget
that that Marxism was a clearly Imperial
a universalist ideology that sought to
conquer the whole world and get
everybody to live according to it to a
single theory so the fact that
progressives continue to believe in
something like that isn't terribly
surprising it's maybe a little bit more
surprising to find people who are or
liberals or classical liberals who are
for a very long time allied with
conservatism even today also advocating
some kind of let's tear down all the
borders and impose a single regime but I
think for me that's personally more
surprising
well it's interesting too from your
vantage in Israel because Israel comes
out is born out of the second world war
a nation for the Jewish people and now
not shortly after the end of the Second
World War we saw that nationalism was
being blamed for the Nazis it was about
nationalist expansion and nationalist
hatred and nationalist fervor and that's
why we all decided we have to totally
get rid of nationalism and become one
big kumbaya a community of people across
the earth you say that this argument and
this common knowledge that we have is
totally ridiculous how so well it's not
totally ridiculous it's just mostly
wrong I mean look if you read about the
policies of somebody like Dwight
Eisenhower
hey Dwight Eisenhower his foreign policy
was was based on fighting imperialism
and supporting nationalism because he
believed in the self-determination of
peoples and you can name lots of others
on the left and on the right with
Woodrow Wilson Teddy Roosevelt in his in
his later years to golf batcher
Gandhi David ben-gurion I mean so many
people who are revered heroic figures
politically and intellectually
subscribed to one version or another of
of a nationalist World Order that it
really takes just an extraordinary
degree of a
Curren to to just blame all of that say
all of that is like Nazism and I just
want to say the deep that that that the
people saying this obviously I mean I
don't recommend it people actually read
mine comp but if you're going to talk
about this it's not fun to read but if
you're going to talk about this subject
it's worth actually looking at what the
Nazis believed the Nazis were from the
first moment and in imperialist movement
whose goal was as Hitler wrote to to
make German in Germany the the mistress
of the globe and the Lord of the earth
his goal was to overthrow the order of
national States which he viewed as
corrupt and and contentious well I
wonder when we look at these historical
examples even in our present time why is
it that the the international community
the Empire builders the advocates of the
European Union and the advocates of the
United Nations or whatever they seem to
support nationalism for certain
countries but not other countries they
seem to support nationalism in other
areas of the world the Middle East
Southeast Asia parts of Africa but then
they want to break down borders in
Europe in the United States and in
Israel why is that why why do these
different countries seem to be treated
differently you're absolutely right and
and the the answer is because this
internationalist worldview you know in
both its progressive and its liberal
forms is descended from an Enlightenment
theory of history which goes an
excellent example is conch which says
that first first a society is tribal and
barbaric and everybody killing one
another then tribes gather to the unite
under a law and peasant nation as the
National States and then they only kill
that the other nations and then finally
you reach
moral maturity what God calls it moral
maturity when you realize that you need
to take down all the borders and unite
in one international state to cover
everything and what's happening is that
that the the progressives and liberals
who support this kind of movement they
look at the third world or Islamic
countries or Southeast Asia the the
countries that you're naming and they
say oh those are just you know the
primitives that barbarian haven't
reached the level of moral maturity that
we've reached but if anyone steps out of
line among the descendants of European
people's you know that could be the UK
with brexit or it could be Israel or the
Trump movement in America or Poland or
Italy the moment you step out of line if
you're descended from you know some kind
of European background then you're
attacked as a traitor
as a traitor to the moral maturity that
that Europeans are supposed to have
reached that's right and it one of the
ironies that you explain in the book is
truly one of the enduring historical
lessons which is that the Jews can't
catch a break and so within 50 years of
the foundation of the Jewish state of
Israel you've got the people who helped
found it say okay pish-posh let's drop
those borders now let's be oh let's be
nice let's have a nice international
community or whatever how did that
change so quickly you know in the in as
you write about in the Bible the Jews
are called out to be a nation not to be
an empire but to be a nation and they
get this nation state in the aftermath
of the Second World War but now all of a
sudden Israel is under attack on every
college campus in America all over the
world people are boycotting Israel but
what is that about
well there was a there was a mistake
that the Americans in the British after
world war ii III I think originally
wanted to see a European Union because
they were trying to build up a strong
continental resistance to so
expansionism but I think that that was
just a terrible mistake and what what
happened is that at an hour and the
other founders of the the European
community just unleashed this this
vision of claiming that the independence
of Nations is the is the cause of
warfare and and therefore the root of
all evil and that that that argument
they guess had tremendous emotional
traction after World War Two among
liberals and Marxists and since you know
as you know the universities and and the
media are very very sympathetic to these
kinds of our arguments and so that they
mean they've been educating an entire
it's now two or three two or three
generations first of Europeans and now
Americans to the idea that national
independence is actually the source of
evil and that concentration of power in
the hands of international bodies is the
solution to it I want to know in what
we're talking about concentrations of
power and you make it pretty clear in
the book there there seems to be a
spectrum here between Anarchy chaos you
know the kind of fever dream of
libertarians maybe in the American right
and Empire the Imperial Order and then
the nation nationalism is somewhere in
the middle of that how do you arrive at
that we hear nationalism bandied about
by everybody from good conservative
Americans to wacko white supremacists
where what is the nation and what makes
nationalism work why is that the best
order for nations well the nation when I
use the term nation I'm using it in in a
traditional traditional way according to
the the Anglo American political
tradition which is which is rooted as
you say in in script
especially in the Hebrew Bibles so if
you take let's say the King James Bible
and you look up the way the word nation
is used in the King James Bible then
you'll get a really good idea of of what
it is that shaped the the English
Scottish Dutch American conception of of
a nation but it's it's it's it's based
on the diversity and unification of the
ancient Israel Israelite tribes in the
Bible but at the same time it's not
based on race in in any way and we know
that because when the Israelites weave
Egypt Egypt that what we're told that
Egyptians joined them and stood at the
foot of Mount Sinai and received the Ten
Commandments and joined the Jewish
people or that Ruth the Moabitess
even though she's a Moabite she she
comes over to Israel and she embraces
she says your people will be my people
and your God will be my god and and when
she adopts that mutual loyalty with the
with the faith of the Jewish people and
belief and it's God then she she becomes
a part of the Jewish people right so the
the biblical concept of a nation is is
not based on race at all it's a
unification of a number of tribes that
are diverse internally but at the same
time share some kind of basic cultural
inheritance around which they can unite
which is usually a language a religion a
legal system and so on well that that is
such a wonderful clarification because
I'm reading it and I'm thinking this is
the best defense of nationalism I've
heard this is a very compelling argument
and and yet I wondered where these you
know they call themselves white
nationalists fit into it because I've
always found their arguments to be weak
to say to put it charitably to not be
very compelling at all and it's it's
just a misunderstanding it seems by
these various xx racists who exist in
America misunderstanding of what the
nation is what the nation has
and throughout history read all of
history well yeah white racism white
nationalism is an oxymoron I mean you
can't have a white nation I mean there
is no white nation there's historically
never been such a thing as a group of
people who are the whites and they are a
nation so that the the whole arguments
the the biblical and anglo-american
arguments is based on the assumption
that nations are not some kind of
fantasy that somebody came up you can't
came up but you can't just say oh people
with blue eyes they're a nation there's
an actual historical thing that is a
nation the French are a nation the Dutch
are a nation the English are a nation
and so on and you can argue on the
margins about whether some group or
another qualifies but but the fact that
there are nations is that they're
distinct from one another and that
they're internally cohesive and that's
that that's an empirical fact now the
question the question that you you asked
before about why is this a good way to
organize the political order so the
argument that I make in the book is is
that is that national political or get a
national form of political organization
where nations are independence but it
fits roughly halfway between conditions
of anarchy where you know like like
every family or every clan is
independent and they're all at war with
one another and at the other extreme a
universal vision where the goal is for
the whole world as much as possible to
be brought under a single legal and
political regime and what what the idea
of independent nations what it does is
it it tries to strike a balance between
the two which is obviously difficult to
maintain but it tries at the same time
both to to embrace the the value of
particularity of particularism of
diversity the different nations are
different from one another and the
competition among nations is in
fact what advances us towards innovation
and and advancements you know in
politics and religion science the arts
so that's on the one hand on the other
hand the the national state does
resemble international empire in that
what it does is it unifies a very large
group of people and and drives warfare
to to the to the periphery of of life so
it creates a an internal sphere of peace
and prosperity the difference between
Empire and national independence is it
is that that the nationalist when he's
behaving himself at least is looking to
take care of his own nation and actually
sees it as a tremendous waste of
resources to fight an unending war at
the other side of the world to conquer
all sorts of other peoples which would
you then don't know how to govern right
III this is something I've always loved
about your writing even beyond the book
I'll let you go because I know you're
very busy and doing the book tour right
now but something I love about it is you
make conservative arguments you don't
make argue liberal arguments as a
conservative you don't say I'm a
conservative because I'm a liberal you
make conservative arguments and it's not
just pie in the sky we're talking about
real facts and things that are
demonstrable in history and therefore
demonstrable
in the way that we should order our
nation's and order our world and one of
those facts is the nation it's a
terribly compelling argument you have to
go read it I encourage everybody to go
read it the virtue of nationalism by
doctor Yoram Hasani dr. Hasani thank you
so much for being here sure thanks so
much more to get to today I'm sorry
though if you're on Facebook and YouTube
how'd you do it how did you manage to
stay on and that get kicked off if
you're not if you're on daily wire.com
thank you very much you help us keep the
lights on in Co FFA in my tumblr but if
you're not sign up it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me Ben Shapiro and replacement Matt
Walsh questions in the conversation
questions in the mailbag that's coming
up tomorrow get your questions in none
of that matters this is what matters the
Kathy Griffin
here's tumblr is that where are we
starting that new vintage I'm litter I'm
in a Twitter fight right now with Kathy
Griffin because she always gets really
angry with me and she said like f you
michael knowles all you all you daily
wire idiots don't know that comedy is
subjective just very funny cuz then
she's angry with us because we
subjectively think she isn't funny
maybe objectively think it either way
it's led to an overflow of Kathy Griffin
tears make sure you get your tumblr or
you're going to drown the only reason
that this studio isn't underwater right
now is because we have the tumblr it's
the FDA approved vessel go to daily wire
calm we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
all right we have some bad election news
today not for the midterm elections that
I'm not convinced about I'm there saying
that the midterm generic ballot is
terrible for Republicans but they always
tell us this there was all Republicans
don't even go out to vote there's no
reason for you even to go vote because
it's gonna you're gonna do so bad and
then we win so I don't really believe
that also because there's no such thing
as a generic congressional candidate
there's no jand when you're talking
about these national polls giant blue
states like California end up giving the
Democrats a disproportionate
representation in these polls so I'm not
that concerned about that what I am
concerned about is a poll that came out
today from The Associated Press which is
that only 25% of Americans think it is
very important for their political
candidates to have religious faith and
this is a major low only 25 percent so
more people think it's moderately
important but this is a big low and it
tells us a lot about the mis-education
of Millennials and it tells us a lot
about the cracking up of institutions
like mainstream mainline Protestantism
and I'm sorry to say Catholicism in
America so you've got to look at these
numbers because when you dig into this
bowl from the AAP you'll learn about the
political views and the views of
candidates but there's another poll from
Pew that came out a little while ago
that shows that the lion's share of
Millennials are religiously unaffiliated
they're not Protestant they're not
evangelical they're not Catholic they're
not there
noticed they're not whatever they're
religiously unaffiliated this number is
double that's that number for their
parents generation and it's triple that
of their grandparents generation really
scary number now why is it scary
well John Adams said that the American
Constitution was built for a moral and
religious people and that it's unfit for
the governance of anyone else that's
because it's a government that allows
you to be free but the only way that
you're allowed to be free the only way
that you can govern yourself is if you
have virtue if you have discipline if
you have a religious foundation that
inculcates those virtuals and that moral
law into you and gives you a view of
what the purpose of your freedom is if
you don't have that you're just going to
descend into Liberty nonsense and not be
able to control yourself we look around
and you know we've got a Burning Man
culture basically it's descended into
chaos and it'll only get worse if you
can't control yourself if you can't
discipline yourself the government is
going to discipline you because you're
not capable of your own freedom you're
not capable of governing yourself I
don't totally blame Millennials for this
though because they've just been miss
educated I don't think that the lion's
share of Millennials have tried
Christianity and found it to be wanting
I think they haven't learned anything
about Christianity at all I think they
haven't been really raised with very
much religion at all and this can be a
great opportunity I mean this look I was
an atheist for 10 years and then it
struck me the intellectual side of it
struck me later the spiritual side of it
struck me the historical the cultural
everything finally hit me and nobody's
more enthusiastic than a revert or a
convert so this this is a good
opportunity but it requires that we show
Millennials what they've been missing
the whole time
this also shows the breakdown of
institutions of mainline Protestantism
and of Catholicism because when you dig
into that a peephole you'll see that
among white evangelical Protestants the
majority of them still believe it is
extremely or very important that a
candidate has strong religious beliefs
so it's still the majority of white
evangelical Protestants and it's not a
racial thing because even among
non-white evangelical Protestants almost
50% 47% believe the same thing that it's
extremely or very important that
candidates for public office have deeply
held religious views when you get down
to Catholics that number drops in half
to 25% when you get down to mainline
Protestants Episcopalians Presbyterians
Methodists whatever it drops even lower
to 18% why is that it's because those
institutions have been hollowed out from
within in the United States even the
Catholic Church we're seeing the crack
up of the Catholic Church now in the US
where bishops have been incredibly
accused of covering up abuse not just
abuse of kids but abuse of seminarians
abusive priests whole sexual networks
within the clergy and credible
allegations from a major archbishop
archbishop vegan oh the former nun CEO
to the u.s. accusing Pope Francis of
being complicit in some of these
cover-ups of priests and seminarians
abuse this is a major issue but that
isn't the whole issue a lot of the issue
is that a lot of churches in America
catholic churches to teach weaksauce
weak religion there was a theologian in
the 20th century I forget his name who
said well I forgot which one it was
who said that most of the sermons that
he heard on Sundays amounted to I might
suggest that you try to be good
that's the homily that's the sermon and
the same thing is obviously it's much
worse among the mainline Protestant
churches which have totally they they've
you know fly PC transgender flags
outside they've adopted the religion of
political correctness and the religion
of modern leftism but it's really bad
because what you're going to end up with
is what Richard neighbor the Christian
ethicist described as a God without
wrath leading a people without sin into
a kingdom without judgment through the
ministrations of Christ without a cross
and that is not true religion and that's
not compelling religion and the pews are
going to empty if they try to teach that
let that religion the the line is that
if you marry yourself to the spirit of
the age you're gonna find yourself a
widow in the next stage and that's what
we're seeing people thought in the
Catholic Church after vatican ii after
the traditional liturgy was nixed and
they started inviting in all the
acoustic guitars and all of the
liturgical craziness they thought that
that would modernize the church that now
we're going to have a huge awakening
what happened the pews emptied and what
i see from my own vantage as a Catholic
is that the traditional liturgies the
Troodon teen mass the Latin services
those are the ones that are filled up
and you when you see it with families
you know you know how the Catholics feel
about babies you see like father mother
kid kid kid kid kid kid kid you know
they're there single-handedly filling up
the pews that is what you need either
that the church is going to be the
church or there won't be a church but
it's not going to become something else
it's not going to become the leftist
hippie dippie happy-hour that isn't
going to compel people for very long
that is a fad and this is true if the
Catholic Church doesn't it's true if the
Methodists do it it's true if anybody
doesn't and I've really got to give
credit where credit is due
to evangelical Protestants in America
who are still in many cases practicing
what they preach there was a survey out
of American Catholics I think also from
pew that showed that roughly half of
American Catholics support abortion
the church is clear about its teaching
on abortion people should be clear about
the teaching on abortion abortion ends a
human life Christ is very clear he says
whatever you do to whoever causes the
littlest one to sin it would be better
for that man if he had a millstone tied
around his neck and were cast into the
bottom of the sea
whoever harms the least of me and things
aren't going to aren't going to turn out
very well for that person and yet half
of American Catholics support abortion
this is insanity clearly they don't
believe what they say that they believe
and either the those churches are going
to be the church and authentically
preach the gospel or they're gonna fall
apart and fall away and you're gonna get
another generation of religiously
unaffiliated and then another and
another until the took to quote I think
it was Pope Benedict the the flames of
Christianity are extinguished throughout
the West that's the direction that we're
headed in and we need some of that old
old-time religion
don't try to I don't I don't think the
rock star churches are going to do that
I think you need to authentically preach
the gospel and then you'll get people
who are taking their religion seriously
John Adams was not a crazy person he was
not just a product of his time he was
not a guy who thought in a shallow way
he knows that this country which exalts
freedom which protects freedom is only
built for a moral and religious people
even if you don't consider yourself
religious give it a second thought
I remember when I was an atheist in
college and Coulter or I would have
called myself an atheist I actually
don't believe atheists really even exist
you know if I don't believe in unicorns
I don't spend all of my life talking
about unicorns so I don't really even
believe they exist but I would have
called myself that and Ann Coulter made
this great argument she said if all you
care about is low taxes and you've got
one guy who's pro-life and one guy who's
pro-choice one guy who's religious one
guy who's irreligious vote for the guy
whose religious who's pro-life was those
cultural aspects to his conservatism he
will lower your taxes more because there
is a coherence to his thought it's okay
if you consider yourself atheist and you
want to lower taxes that's that's better
than being a leftist but there is a
coherence to that thought that you
you've got to you've got to understand
and we get a lot of this out of the
the framers and the founders of the
country now to attack the Catholic
Church even more not really do I attack
the church but to attack people who were
abusing the church and to attack
corruption in the church we have heard
from Pope Francis Pope Francis who said
I will not say one word about this
scandal I will not say one word about
the accusations credibly made against me
I will not say one word about this now
he's saying some words he's saying
multiple words he is now blaming the
exposure of this corruption in the
bishops and in the clergy not on the
bishops but on Satan he's blaming the
exposure of that corruption he's not
even blaming the corruption he's blaming
the fact that we now can see it that a
light has been shed on this he's blaming
that on Satan he said quote in these
times it seems like the great accuser
has been Unchained and is attacking the
bishops true we're all sinners we
bishops he tries to uncover the sins so
they are visible in order to scandalize
the people the great accuser is he
himself says to God in the first chapter
of the book of Job roams the earth
looking for someone to accuse it bishops
strength against the great accuser is
prayer that of Jesus in his own and the
humility of being chosen a remaining
close to the people of God without
seeking an aristocratic life that
removes this unction let us pray today
for our bishops for me for those who are
here and for all of Bishops throughout
the world every response has been so
totally tone deaf as so totally missed
the point yes Satan is the accuser Satan
does accuse people the trouble with the
church right now is that theirs is is
not that there's too much shame that
there is there are too many accusations
the trouble with the church is that
there are rotten corrupt bishops who
were covering up for sex abuse for
decades and they're lying through their
teeth and they need to be rooted out
because they're a scandal Christ talks
about it he talks about the millstones
he remember the millstones people it
this is a really really tone-deaf
response and we've heard this before
but when the last time that Pope Francis
responded after he said he wasn't going
to respond he said that people who were
talking about these things should be
silent and pray yes people should pray
but he told them to shut up
this is not the right response and
you're gonna see those numbers those
religiously unaffiliated go up and up
and up as long as this sort of
corruption is is being tolerated by the
Vatican or by bishops in the United
States really really upsetting to see
them but sit we're running late again
we're always running late okay well
we've got a lot more to talk about an
attorney general candidate in New York
has really really stepped in it she's
violated the only rule that matters to
the left which if they didn't have
double standards would have no standards
at all we'll just have to get to it
tomorrow I want to leave you on this
note however there was a video that came
out yesterday on the anniversary of 9/11
it is perhaps the most American thing
I've ever seen I'll just play it for you
right now hey guys we're out here live
on the highway 10 bridge I want to show
you what's going on here on the bridge
look what landed on top of the aerial on
9/11 isn't that unbelievable
this Eagle just landed on the aerial
while we're doing the 9/11 memorial
phenomenal
really incredible does make you think
about the role of Providence in America
from the founding of the country from
the Mayflower all the way to the present
there does seem to be a providential
hand even as the religiously
unaffiliated increase and increase and
increase maybe that should all give us
some thought we've got a lot more to
talk about tomorrow in the meantime I'll
see you then get your mailbag questions
and I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you soon
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy Board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you